「量子情報と計算の理解」へようこそ。私の名前はJohn Watusで、IBM Quantumの教育担当
テクニカルディレクターだ。これはシリーズのeth番目のレッスンで、量子アルゴリズムを扱う
シリーズ第二ユニットの最後のレッスンだ。計算のクエリモデルについて、量子
アルゴリズムがそのモデル内で古典アルゴリズムに対して証明可能な優位性をもたらす例も含めて話してきた。量子
アルゴリズムに関連する基礎的な概念や、計算コストをどう測るかについても議論し、前のレッスンでは位相推定とShorの
アルゴリズムについて議論した。このレッスンでは、量子が
古典アルゴリズムに対して二次的な優位性をもたらすGroverのアルゴリズムを取り上げる。これはいわゆる非構造化探索問題に対するもので、
レッスンに入ってから詳しく説明する。これらはすべて量子アルゴリズムに関する基礎的なトピックだ。他にも量子
アルゴリズムや、異なる量子アルゴリズムと量子アルゴリズム技法を統合する一般的なパラダイムも存在する。
興味があれば、既知の量子アルゴリズムを分類し多くの参考文献を含むquantum algorithm Zooをぜひチェックしてみてほしい。
その発展に貢献してきたオリジナルの研究論文も掲載されている。ただし、このシリーズでは
基礎に絞る。次のレッスンから新しいトピックに移るが、
まずGroverのアルゴリズムについて話そう。レッスンの概要はこうだ。まず
取り上げる計算問題、すなわち非構造化探索についての簡単な議論から始める。直感的に言えば、
非構造化探索問題とは、ソートされておらず有用な順序付けもされていないアイテムの集合を
探索することだと考えられる。次に、古典アルゴリズムに対して二次的な優位性をもたらす量子アルゴリズムである
Groverのアルゴリズムについて議論し、それが具体的に何を意味するかはすぐに説明する。このアルゴリズムの非常に高レベルな説明は、
まず初期化ステップがあり、次に私がGrover
操作と呼ぶ演算を何度か繰り返し、最後に測定を行って候補となる
探索問題の解を得るというものだ。Grover操作が何であるか、そして
量子コンピュータ上でどう実装できるかを説明し、この操作の分析を通じて何をするものかや探索に有用である理由を
よりよく理解していく。レッスンの第三部は、反復回数に関するものだ。
つまり、Groverのアルゴリズムにおいて、アルゴリズムが探している対象を
見つけることに成功する可能性を最大化しつつ、コストを最小化するために、Grover操作を何回適用すべきかということだ。
まず、解がちょうど一つしかない特殊ケースである一意的探索問題から始め、
次に複数の解がある場合に何が起きるかを考察する。最後に
Groverのアルゴリズムとその一般化についての簡単な考察でレッスンを締めくくる。では
レッスン全体を通じて扱う計算問題から始めよう。まず、いつものように
SigmaでバイナリアルファベットをΣで表すことにする。この表記はレッスン全体で使うので、毎回
説明するのは省略する。長さnのバイナリ文字列をバイナリアルファベットに写す関数fがあるとしよう。
この関数を簡単に評価できるというのが前提だ。
例えば、サイズがnの多項式であるBoolean circuitがこの関数にあるとする。だからといってこれが
任意の意味で単純な関数だとか、この関数について特によく理解しているということにはならない。例えば、
fを計算するための、さまざまな入力文字列で評価できるかなり複雑で煩雑なBoolean circuitはあるが、必ずしも
扱いやすい良い形ではないかもしれない。目標は、解を見つけることだ。
ここで「解」とは、fを1に評価させる長さnのバイナリ文字列を意味する。一般にこれは非常に難しい
計算問題だ。少なくともそう思われる。特に、入力が実際に
関数fを計算するためのBoolean circuitの記述である場合、これはいわゆるNP完全問題となる。この問題を
形式化する一つの方法はクエリ問題としてで、このレッスンの目的のためには
この問題をクエリモデルの文脈で純粋に考えるのが妥当だ。しかしこの
問題が実際にどこで・いつ生じるかを考えると、fがBoolean
circuitによって計算されると考える方がより自然だ。ただし、第六レッスンで見たように、Boolean circuitを取り上げて
クエリ操作またはquery gateを実装するためのQuantum circuitに変換するという構成を通じて、これら二つの観点を結びつけることができる。いずれにしろ、概念的に言えば
この問題への入力はこの関数fで、存在すれば解を探している。もし
解がない、つまりfが定数ゼロ関数だとわかった場合、正しい出力は
解なしと報告することだ。これは非構造化探索問題と呼ばれ、
解を見つけやすくするようなfの特別な性質がないという意味だ。
既にソートされているデータや、探索を容易にするデータ構造に格納されているデータを探索しているわけではなく、
助けになるような関数fへの約束もない。考え方の一つとしては、
名前を探す場合と対比した電話帳で電話番号を探すようなものだ。名前はアルファベット順に
並べられている前提なので名前の方がずっと簡単だ。実用的な観点では、これは本当にデータ探索の話ではない。
データは探索しやすい形で整理・保存されるものだ。これはむしろ
複雑な方程式の解を探すことや、あるいは
鍵を開ける組み合わせを探すことに近い。余談として、このモデルの実用的な関連性をどう感じるかに関係なく、この問題をクエリモデルの文脈で考えることには意味がある。
もちろん現実にはオラクルやブラックボックスは存在しないが、そうでないとわかるまでは、
複雑で謎めいたBoolean circuitはブラック
ボックスのようなものだ。では、この非構造化探索問題を解くアルゴリズムを考えてみよう。ここでは
簡単のためクエリモデルで行う。関数にブラックボックスではなくBoolean circuitがある場合でも
クエリアルゴリズムを実行できるが、もちろんクエリを使わない新しいアルゴリズムが
この問題に対して発見される可能性も排除できない。ただしその
可能性については気にしないことにする。まず少し記法の話をする。関数fへの入力文字列の総数は2の
小文字のnは、Fへのインプットstringのlengthのことだ。これ以降、大文字のNを2の
小文字n乗、つまりこの数のことと定義する。大文字で2の小文字乗を表すのは
よくある慣習だ。大文字Nという数についてはかなり頻繁に話すことになるので、これは
便利な表記だし、少しすっきりさせるのにも役立つ。なおこの表記はこの
レッスン全体を通じて使われる。さて、search Problemを古典的に解くには、単純に
全ての可能なnビットstringを任意の順番で順次調べ、それぞれにFを評価すればいい。
どこかで解が見つかれば止まれるが、最悪の場合はすべての
inputに対してFを評価することになる。つまり、大文字N回の
queryが必要だ。この計算のコストをqueryの回数だけでなく別の方法で測ることも考えられるが、queryの回数は
関数fを評価しなければならない回数を表しており、fの評価がコストを
支配すると考えるのは合理的だ。実はこれが決定的アルゴリズムで可能な最善だ。
これもquery modelの文脈の話だ。すべてのinput
stringのうち一つを除いて全部queryし、Fがそれまで全てのstringに対して0を返していた場合、残りの最後の
stringが解でないとどうして確信できるだろうか。答えは、確信できない。だから最悪の場合、n回すべてのqueryが必要なんだ。
乱択を使うこともできる。解が存在するときに解を見つけるために必要な
期待query数を減らすなど、ごくわずかな改善が得られる。または正確性の
確率とqueryの削減をトレードオフすることもできる。しかしどう考えても、queryの回数はNに対して線形な数が
必要だ。つまり古典的には、線形な、すなわち
大文字N線形の回数のqueryが必要だ。Groverのアルゴリズムは、searchをより少ない回数で行う量子アルゴリズムだ。必要なのはbigo
√n回のqueryだ。それらのqueryはsuperpositionで起きるのでmagicじゃないが、
古典的に可能なものに対して大きな改善だ。これがquadratic
advantageの意味だ。量子の古典に対するこのquadratic advantageは、実際に実用的な
advantageに変えられるだろうか。近い将来はたぶん無理だが、遠い未来はわからない。でも仮に
Groverのアルゴリズムがsearchで実用的なadvantageをもたらさないとしても、それは量子アルゴリズムの
基礎の重要な部分として理解する価値がある。Groverのアルゴリズム本体に進む前に、
「phase query gate」と呼ばれるものについて少し話す必要がある。query modelの多くの量子アルゴリズムは、自然に
phase query gateを使って表現される。そしてGroverのアルゴリズムはその
具体例だと分かるだろう。まず通常のquery gateの概要から始めよう。先ほど話していた形の関数fに対して、
query gate UFはstandard basis stateに対して画面に示すように定義される。
standard basis stateのsuperpositionに対する作用は線形性によって決まる。そして思い出してほしいのだが、fのBoolean circuitから、このUF演算のcircuitをBoolean circuitのsizeに対して
線形なコストで実際に構築できるということだ。一方、fのphase query gateは
ZFという名前で表し、このように動作する。特にこのgateは
小文字n個のqubitに作用する。小文字n+1個のqubitに作用するUFとは対照的に、このgateは関数値を自動的に
phaseに「kick」する。UFのように出力値を追加のqubitにXORするのではなく、
phaseに反映させるわけだ。UFゲートにphase kickbackを使うとどうなるかを考えると、
基本的にはZF gateを実装しているだけだ。minus stateが必要で、UFの評価が1回コストとして
かかる。ただし、minus stateは実際に戻ってくるので、次にも使いたければ使えるし、
捨ててもいい。これがphase query gateだ。もし
phase query gate ZFだけが与えられていて、それが関数fにアクセスする唯一の手段だとしたら、
UF gateを実際には再現できない。しかし、ZFのcontrolled版があれば
UF gateを構築できる。
それは練習問題として残しておこう。関数fのphase query gateに加えて、nビット
OR関数のphase query gate、つまり全ゼロstringが与えられたときに0を返し、それ以外では
1を返す関数も必要だ。具体的にZORがstandard basis stateにどう作用するかは画面に示してある。
このgateは関数fに依存しないので、
queryは不要だ。この演算を実装するQuantum circuitを構築する一つの方法は、
関数fの場合と同様に行うことだ。ただし今回はnビットのOR関数を計算するBoolean circuitから始める。
そうすれば、これらのgateが揃ったので次の
セクションに進む準備ができた。次はGroverのアルゴリズムについて、アルゴリズムの説明から始めて議論しよう。まずは
小文字n個のqubitをそれぞれplus stateに初期化する。つまり、これらのqubitをlength nの全ての
binary stringの等しいsuperpositionに置く。これらのqubitのstateを
解に向けて「steer」していくことが目標だ。この状態からスタートするのは直感的で、まだ関数fについて何も知らないからだ。
この時点ではどのstringも等しく解である可能性があり、それはこれらのqubitが全stringの等しいsuperpositionにあるという事実に反映されている。
そして反復する。Grover操作を繰り返し適用する。これがアルゴリズムの
核心であり、すぐに説明する。この操作を合計T回適用する。Tは何らかの非負の
整数だ。ただしこの数はアルゴリズム自体では指定されていない。Tを何らかの方法で選ぶ必要がある。次の
セクションではTの良い選び方について話す。しかし今は、反復回数tを
任意のものとして考えておこう。最後に、standard basisで測定すると、
候補となる解が得られる。それが解であるという保証はないが、Tを上手く選べば
解が得られる確率を大きくできる。そしてこれがGrover操作だ。
それ自体、Gと名付けたものだが、これはN qubitすべてに対する演算の合成だ。つまりこれはN
qubit演算で、まずZF gate、言い換えると関数fに対する位相クエリgateがある。
入力関数fに対して、その後にHadamard gateの層が続き、次にzorがある。これはor関数に対する位相クエリgateだ。
そして最後にHadamard gateの層がもう一つある。つまりステップ2の1回の反復は
ここに示された形のcircuitで実装できるとわかる。ちなみにここでは4つのqubitがある。
でも一般的には任意の数のqubitを使える。ここで重要なのは、Gをimplementするためにはfへのクエリが1回必要だということだ。
ZFをimplementするためにもクエリが1回必要で、他の演算はどれもfに依存しないからクエリは不要だ。だからこのTという数は
ステップ2でGを適用する回数を表すと同時に、必要なクエリの回数も表している。
Groverのアルゴリズムの典型的な使い方を紹介するが、これが唯一の使い方ではないと言ったよね。
まず最初にTを選ぶ必要があって、それについては次のセクションで詳しく説明する。
どんなTを選んでも、Groverのアルゴリズムをそのiterationsだけ実行して候補解を得る。
Xという解が得られるが、Xが本当に解である保証はない。でも追加でクエリを1回使って確認できる。解であれば
その解を出力して終了できる。そうでなければ、異なるTで再試行するか
必ずしもそうしなくてもいいが、または諦めて解がないと報告できる。さっきも言ったように
これはアルゴリズムの唯一の使い方ではないが、探索問題への自然な適用方法だ。次に、grover operationが
作用するN qubitの状態に対して実際に何をするかを見ていく。n個のqubitを
1つのregisterとして考えて、Qと名付けることにしよう。まずGroverの
アルゴリズムで最初にやることは、すべてのnビット文字列の一様重ね合わせにQを置くことで、全ゼロ状態のn qubitにHadamard
gateを適用してそれをやる。次にgrover operation Gをiterateして、それから
測定する。すべてのnビット文字列の集合を2つの集合、AzとA1に分けると便利だ。
AzはFを評価するとゼロになる文字列をすべて含み、A1はFを評価すると
1になる文字列をすべて含む。別の言い方をすると、A1は探索
問題のすべての解を含み、Azはすべての非解を含む。特に
2つのquantum stateに興味がある。一つはすべての非解に対する一様重ね合わせで、それがket Azで、もう
一つはすべての解に対する一様重ね合わせで、それがket A1だ。これらの定義が意味をなすのは
集合が空でない場合だけで、そうでなければゼロを合計してゼロで割ることになる。この
Groverのアルゴリズムの分析を通じて、その仮定をおいていく。fが定数ゼロ関数か定数1関数のとき
Groverのアルゴリズムが何をするかは特殊ケースとして簡単に求められるが、それは
自分でやってみてほしい。当然ながら、すべての文字列が解であれば、測定したときに解が得られる。
解が全くない場合は解が得られない。なぜならその場合に解が存在しないからだ。
でもこの分析では、これら2つの集合がどちらも空でないと仮定して、これらの
2つの状態の定義が意味をなすようにする。ちなみに、これはよくある
記法で、空でない有限集合sがある場合、ket sと書くとその集合の要素に対する一様重ね合わせを意味する。
ここにある通りだ。これらの定義をまとめて、Groverのアルゴリズムとどう繋がるかを見ていく。
Groverのアルゴリズムの最初のステップは初期化ステップで、Qをすべてのnビット文字列に対する一様
重ね合わせに置く。この状態にわかりやすい名前をつけると
ket uと呼ぶことにする。uはuniformの略だ。分析のために最初に注意しておくべき重要なことは
この一様状態ket uが、2つのベクトルket a0とket
A1が張る部分空間に含まれているということだ。特に、ここに示した2つの状態の線形結合を取るとket
uが得られる。分析全体の鍵は、Qの状態がgrover operationを何度適用しても
この2次元部分空間に留まり続けるという事実だ。つまりすべては
2次元部分空間で何が起きるかに帰着する。では、grover operationが何をするか、特に
ket a0とket A1が張る2次元部分空間のベクトルに対して何をするかを見ていく。
gを2つの部分に分けて考えると便利で、一方はZF
gateで、もう一方はHadamard gateの2つの層の間に挟まれたzor gateだ。
ZFの定義はさっきの通りで、その定義から、非解と解の一様重ね合わせという
2つの状態への作用は、単純にket A1の前にマイナス符号を付けるだけというのは直感的にわかる。
ket a0には何も起きないし、この分析ではZFについてはそれだけ知っていれば十分だ。
2つ目の部分については、
Hadamardの2つの層の間に挟まれたzor gateだが、zorがどう定義されるかを思い出すところから始めよう。一つの書き方は
ここに示したように、これは以前と同じ式で、direct記法を使った別の表現は
このようになる。右辺の演算が標準基底状態にどう作用するかを考えると、この式を確認できる。
特に全ゼロ状態には何もしないで、他のすべての標準基底状態にはマイナス符号が付き、これはZ
orの定義と一致する。この演算をHadamard gateの2つの層の間に挟むと、同様の式が得られるが
全ゼロ標準基底状態の代わりに一様重ね合わせket uが現れる。それはH tensor
nがL zero標準基底状態をket uに変換するからで、またH tensor nはそれ自身の共役転置でもあるから、
ketではなくbraに対して右から作用する場合も同様に機能する。これで
先ほど観察した事実を使って、Gが2つのベクトルa0とA1に対して何をするかを求める。
まずa0から始めよう。まず、Hadamardの2つの層の間に挟まれたzor gateの式を
代入する。次に、ZFがket
a0に何もしないという事実と、Hadamardの2つの層の間に挟まれたzor gateを使う。
cat a zに対してZF演算を除去できる。そしてここにあるcat Uの記述を使うと
K a0とK A1が直交する単位ベクトルであるという事実と合わせて、
このbraとこのcatの積を計算できて、得られる結果は非解の個数の平方根を
nで割ったものだ。この事実を使って結果を評価し、cat Uの式を代入して
整理すると、画面に示された最終結果が得られる。特に注目してほしいのは、この
ベクトルが、先ほど示したようにK a0とK A1で張られる2次元部分空間に含まれているという点だ。
さらに係数が実数であることも常に確認すべきで、自分のペースで
確かめてほしい。こういった内容はこの動画では駆け足で進める傾向があるので、
必要であれば動画を一時停止して考えてみてほしい。では整理して
最終結果を後で使えるように保存しよう。次はベクトルk
A1について同様のことをやる。Gの同じ式を使えて、今度はZF gateが
マイナス符号を注入する。これは演算の中の2項を入れ替えたことで反映されている。
括弧内の処理は非常に似た流れで進み、最終結果も似ているが、2つの係数が
入れ替わって、一方の前にマイナス符号が付く。これは代数の計算結果によるもので、同様に
自分のペースで確認できる。再び2つのベクトルK a0と
K A1の実数線形結合になっていることに気づくだろう。こちらも整理して、もう一方の結果と並べると、Gが
2つのベクトルで張られる部分空間にどう作用するかがわかる。それを表す方法の1つが、画面に示された2x2行列Mだ。
ここで何をしているか明確にしておくと、第1行と第1
列をK a0に、第2行と列をKat A1に対応させている。このシリーズではここまで行列を
標準基底状態への演算の作用を記述するために使ってきたが、行列は
標準基底状態に限らず、異なるベクトルの集合への線形写像の作用を記述するためにも一般的に使われる。ここではGがK a0とK A1にどう作用するかを論じている。
K a0とK A1のspanにある任意のベクトルにGがどう作用するかについて、
この行列Mをより詳しく見ることでさらに多くのことが言える。具体的にわかるのは、
Mが回転行列であるということ。つまりこの2次元空間への作用はある固定した角度による回転として記述できる。
これを確認する方法はいくつかあって、一つは
この行列Mが、見た目がやや単純な行列の2乗として表せるということに気づくことだ。Mだけを見ると気づきにくいかもしれないが、
自分で発見する必要はなく、検証するだけでよい。それは右辺の行列を
2乗するだけで確かめられる。右辺の行列を2乗を除いて書き換えると
画面のようになる。これは角度Thetaによる回転を
行列として記述する典型的な形だ。回転の正確な角度は解の個数の平方根を
nで割ったものの逆正弦だ。ちなみに初めて登場するので指摘しておくと、
この角度はとても重要で、この
解析を続ける中で繰り返し登場する。逆正弦の引数は0から1の間の数で、具体的には
ここでの逆正弦の解釈は、正弦をとったときに引数が得られるような0からPi/2の間の角度だ。
以上が、2乗してMを得た行列についての考え方の一つだ。
行列を2乗することは2回適用することと同じなので、Mは代わりにThetaではなく
2 * Thetaの回転として書けることがわかる。2乗することでThetaの角度で
2回回転するからだ。ちなみに参考になれば、これ全体を別の方法で確認する方法は、Mのこの最終的な式から始めて
三角関数の倍角公式を使ってMの元の式を
導くことだ。これがGのK a0とK A1で張られる部分空間への作用を記述するMの式で、
今後最も役立つものだ。ここでGroverのアルゴリズム自体に戻ると、
初期化ステップ後、Gを適用する前のn qubit registerであるQの状態はcat uだ。
全nビット列上の一様重ね合わせで、K a0とK A1による同じcat uの式がここにある。
この角度Thetaを特定したことで、cat uを
cosine Theta * k a 0 + sin Theta * K
A1と書き換えられることがわかる。K A1の係数については明らかで、もう一方の係数はa0のサイズとa0の
A1のサイズの和がnであることから、基本的な三角法で求められる。これが出発点の状態で、
初めてGを適用すると2 * Thetaの角度で回転するので、全体の角度は3 *
Thetaになる。さらにGを適用すると角度は5 Thetaになる。追加で
2 Theta回転するからだ。このようにGをT回適用した後の
状態は画面のように表される。状態の角度は2T + 1 * Thetaで、これはGの各適用で2 * Theta増加し、
最初の状態がThetaだったことによる追加のThetaを加えたものだ。
grover演算の作用を幾何学的にも考えることができて、これはregister Qの状態が
なぜ回転するかを理解する助けになる。主なアイデアはこうだ。grover
演算は既に特定した2つの部分の合成だ。一つはZFで、もう一つはzまたは
Hadamar gateの2層の間に挟まれたものだ。この2つの部分は
反射であり、2つの反射を合成すると回転が得られる。これがどう機能するか詳しく
見てみよう。まずZFに注目して、注目する空間を
cat a0とKat A1で張られる、先ほどから話している
同じ2次元部分空間に限定する。既に観察したように、この空間へのZFの作用は非常に単純で、
cat a zには何もせず、K A1の前にマイナス符号を付ける。これは反射であり、具体的には
これはK a0に平行な直線についての反射で、名前をつけるとしたらL1と呼ぶ
なぜ反射なのかを理解するには図を描くといい。ここに2つのベクトルK
a0とK A1があって、これらは直交する単位ベクトルだ。スクリーンはこれら2つのベクトルの実数
線形結合全体からなると考えられる。つまり円は、係数が
実数である単位ベクトル全体を表している。これがK a0に平行な直線L1で、円上のある
任意のベクトルsを考えると、ZFを適用した効果はスクリーンで示されているようにこの直線について反射することだ
単純に、k a zには何もせず、K
A1の前にマイナス符号をつけるだけだからだ。sがk a zeroの場合は、この反射を行っても何も起きない。sが
K A1の場合、反射によって負のK A1まで移動する。これはZFの作用と一致する。だからZFは
ここで可視化したような反射だ。Gの2番目の部分、つまりzを
2層のHadamard gateで挟んだものは、2 * K Bru からidentity Matrixを引いたものとして表せると
すでに見た通りだ。これも反射で、今度はK a0ではなくk uに平行な直線L2についての反射だ
この操作はZFと同様の方法で可視化できる。ここにベクトルk
（仮定として）があり、これがKに平行な直線L2で、任意のベクトルSへの作用は
この場合L2である直線についての反射だ
最後に、先ほど述べたように、2つの反射を合成すると回転が得られる。具体的には
反射の軸の間の角度の2倍の回転になる。では似たような
図を描いてみよう。これが2つの反射の軸で、その間の角度がThetaだ
任意のベクトルsを最初の直線L1で反射し、
次に2番目の直線L2で反射すると、正味の効果はベクトルsを2*Thetaの角度だけ回転させることだ
これは一般的に成り立つことで、自分でいくつか例を試してみれば確かにそうなることが確認できる
ともかく、これでGrover演算がベクトルを回転させる効果を持つ理由について直感が得られたなら幸いだ
次に、Groverのalgorithmにおける反復回数Tの選択という問題に移ろう
まず、これまでに見た分析、つまりGrover演算が何をするかを明らかにする分析が、
一様重ね合わせに繰り返し適用したときに、解きたいタスク、つまり探索問題の解を見つけるということとどう関係するかを考えよう
言い換えると、集合A1に含まれる任意の文字列を見つけることだ。簡単に言うと、
目標を設定して、Grover演算を何回適用すればその目標に近づけるかを求める
まず、2つのベクトルK a0とK
A1の線形結合である任意の状態を考えよう。この状態に標準基底測定を行うと、集合A1、つまり
探索問題の解の集合に属する結果が得られる確率は、K A1の係数の絶対値の二乗に等しい。スクリーンに示された
ベクトルの場合、その係数はbetaだ。直感的に言うと、状態K a0を測定すれば
ランダムな非解が得られ、K A1を測定すればランダムな解が得られる。だからこの状態を測定すれば
確率|Alpha|^2でランダムな非解が得られ、確率
|beta|^2でランダムな解が得られる。ただ、少し時間をかけて計算してみることもできる。このベクトルの
標準基底状態における各成分がわかるように書き出した状態がこれだ。測定した場合、これが
各結果を得る確率で、解が得られる確率を求めるには全ての可能な解の
確率を合計する。これにより期待通り|beta|^2が得られる
さて、T回反復してGroverのalgorithmを実行したときに何が起きるかはすでに分析した。スクリーンに示された状態が
得られる。K A1の係数は
sin(2T + 1) * Thetaで、ここでも重要な角度Thetaが登場する
解が得られる確率はsin^2(2T + 1) *
Thetaだ。この確率をできるだけ1に近づけたい。だからGを反復して状態
ベクトルを回転させる際、K A1を目標状態として考え、
この状態に近づくようにTを選ぼう。また、クエリ数はTなので
Tを最小化したいことも念頭に置いておこう。この確率を1に近づけつつTを最小化したいなら、
状態ベクトルの角度をPi / 2に近づけるのが理にかなっている。sinの二乗を大きくするための最小の角度だからだ
つまり確率を大きくする最初のチャンスだ。状態ベクトルを
回転させていく中で、Tは整数でなければならないからこの角度pi / 2を正確に達成できるとは限らない
だが大まかに考えてTを不等式として解くと、理想的には
TをPi / 4 * Theta引く12にするのが
良いとわかる。ただしTは非負整数でなければならないから、
この理想値に最も近い整数、すなわちPiを4 *
Thetaで割った値の床関数（floor）を取る。ちなみに床関数とは小数部分を切り捨てること、
つまり対象以下の最大の整数を返すものだ。この式によれば、
理想値がちょうど整数の中間にある場合は切り上げるが、このレッスンでは
全くそれは問題にならない。というわけで、これ以降はこの特定の
Tの選択に注目していく。ただしもう一つ重要な考慮事項がある。TのこのspecificationはThetaに依存し、
Thetaは解の数に依存するため、
解の数にも依存するということだ。今後、解の数、つまり
集合a oneのサイズを表すのに便宜上sという文字を使う。ともかく要点は、
Tの式、良い値だと仮説を立てているこの値がThetaに依存し、ThetaはSに依存するということだ
集合A1のサイズだ。解の数が事前にわかってれば問題ないが、
解の数が事前にわからない場合はThetaが不明なので、こういうふうにTを選べない。
だから別の方法を取る必要がある。sがわからない場合については少し後で戻るが、
まずは解の数がわかってる状況に焦点を当てよう。最初は一意探索から始める。
これは唯一の解が必ず存在することが保証された状況で、その解を探す問題だ。
一意探索問題については、レッスン
5でクエリ問題の例として紹介した。入力はnビットから1ビットへの関数fで、唯一のnビット
文字列がFを1に評価させる。目標はその文字列を出力することだ。
これは今まで話してきた非構造化探索問題と等価だが、解がちょうど1つあるという約束付きだ。実際、これは
Groverが1996年の論文で考えた唯一のバージョンの探索問題で、Groverの
algorithmを導入した論文だ。一意探索ではs=1なので、この重要な角度Thetaは逆正弦
の1/nの平方根に等しい。nが大きい場合、この値は約√(1/N)になる。
これは角度が小さくなるほど正弦関数が恒等関数に近づくからだ。
その近似値をTの選択式に代入すると、Tは約πを4で割った√nの床関数になる。
nの平方根のオーダーのクエリを使う方向に進んでるから良い感じだ。
ただこの時点ではアルゴリズムが実際にどれほど機能するかはまだ詳しく見ていない。
N=128、つまり2の7乗の例を見てみよう。
関数fは7ビットから1ビットへのものだ。唯一の解があると仮定してるが、アルゴリズムの
性能を調べるには角度Thetaだけ考えれば十分で、計算できる。
約0.0885ラジアン、つまり5°強だ。その値を
Tの式に代入すると8になる。128個の選択肢から唯一の解を8回のクエリで探す場合を考えている。
状態がどのように変化するかを示す図を描いて、Grover operationの繰り返しとともにどう変わるか見よう。
以前と同様に、状態|A0⟩と|A1⟩がある。
このケース、つまり一意探索では、|A1⟩は実際には一意の解に対応する標準基底の状態だ。
一方|A0⟩は唯一の解以外の全文字列上の一様重ね合わせだ。全文字列上の一様重ね合わせはこれで、
cosΘ|A0⟩+sinΘ|A1⟩と書ける。|A0⟩と
|U⟩が近いのはこの場合理にかなっている。今観察したように|A0⟩は
ほぼ全文字列上の一様重ね合わせだからだ。
欠けている文字列は唯一の解だけだ。Gをもう一度適用すると2Θだけ回転する。
これが2回目の反復後の状態だ。3、4、5、6、7、8回目もある。
|A1⟩にかなり近づいている。ここで止めて測定すれば、
唯一の解が得られる可能性がかなり高い。実際このケースでは、唯一の解が得られない確率は約0.5%しかない。
一方、推奨された8回を超えてGrover operationを適用し続けると、
解が得られる確率は下がり、状態が円を描いて動くにつれて時間とともに振動するようになる。
だから高い確率で成功したければ、正しいタイミングで反復を止めることが重要だ。
Tの選択が一意の解を明らかにする確率について、異なるnの値に対してより一般的に考えよう。
pn1と書いてGrover's algorithmが一意の解を見つけることに成功する確率を表そう。
nの各値について、1は解が1つという意味で、この表記法を他の解の数に拡張する。
2の小さい累乗に対するこれらの確率の表がある。n=2から始まると、
確率は1/2でそれほど良くないが、n=4では確率がちょうど1になり完璧に機能する。
この2つのケース、特にn=4のケースを明示的に確認することは良い演習だ。
n=4のケースでは4つの選択肢から1つの解を探している。
クエリが1回だけ必要で完璧に機能する。nが大きくなるにつれて多少の揺らぎはあり、確率は
少し上下するが、1に近づいていくようだ。実際それは正しく、解析的に証明できる。
確率は常に少なくとも1-1/nであることが証明できる。良い結果だ。
アルゴリズムは完璧ではなく、解が得られることは保証されていないが、特に大きな
nの値に対してはかなり高い確率だ。n=4のときに起こる非常に興味深い異常もある。
また、測定を含むアルゴリズム全体を何度でも実行できることも指摘しておこう。いずれかの実行が
成功すれば解が得られる。だからこれらの確率が十分でなければ、アルゴリズムを再実行するだけで簡単に確率を上げられる。
実際、これらの確率が全て1/2だったとしても、
有用な探索アルゴリズムになる。では複数の解がある場合に何が起こるかを考えよう。
前と似た例から始めよう。n=128だが、今回は
解の数sは1ではなく4だ。再びThetaとTを計算すると、
Thetaは約0.1777、つまり10°強で、Tは
4になる。角度は前の例の約2倍で、Tは半分だ。
前と同様に図を描こう。これが
開始点だ。1回、2回、3回、4回の反復だ。今回は|A1⟩にかなり近い。
解が得られる確率は今回
99.9%以上だ。しかし何も知らずに解が1つだけだと思い込んでいたら、T=8にして
ほぼ−|A0⟩まで回転してしまい、成功確率が非常に小さくなる。
これはTの良い選択と悪い選択があることをさらに示す例で、ここでそれが見える。
S=1に対して良い選択がS=4に対しては非常に悪い選択になることがあるが、Sを事前に知っていると仮定して
仕様に従ってTを選べば、Groverのアルゴリズムが解を見つけることがわかる
確率は少なくとも1 - x/n以上で、多くの場合はそれよりもずっと大きくなる。またs/N以上でもあるが
それは実はあまり面白くない。より興味深いのは、s/Nという割合が小さくなるにつれて、境界が
成功確率の上限が1に近づいていくことだ。既に何度か述べたように
Tという数は、Grover演算の反復回数だけでなく、クエリ数も
表している。ではこの数はsとnにどう依存するのか
まず、xが0と1の間にある場合、arcsinのxは常にx以上であるという事実から始めよう
arcsin関数のテイラー展開を知っていれば簡単に示せるが、他の推論方法もある。ここではこれを
所与のものとして受け入れる。つまりΘは少なくともs/nの
平方根以上であり、したがってTはπ/4 × √(n/s)以下となる
これは実際にはBig O of root nよりも良い結果だ。sがnに対して
大きいほど、必要なクエリ数は少なくなる。ある意味でこの割合が現れるのは
その逆数がΘを定義することを考えれば驚くことではない。結局のところΘこそがこの
分析において本当に重要なものだ。今見てきたように、Groverのアルゴリズムは解の数を
事前に知っているときはうまく機能する。しかし解の数を知らない場合はどうすればいいか
かなりシンプルなアプローチが一つある。それは反復回数を
ランダムに選ぶことだ。具体的には、Tを1からπ/4 × √nの床関数までの間で一様ランダムに選ぶと
これはかなり良い方法だとわかる。この範囲の上限はUnique searchで選ぶクエリ数とほぼ同じで、実際に
ほとんどの場合で正確に正しい数だ。これはΘという角度が取り得る最小値のときで
解が全くないという自明なケースを除く。ここでのアイデアは、解の数を知っていたときのように状態ベクトルを|A1⟩に
慎重に向けるのではなく、ランダムな角度で回転させることだ。まるで
状態ベクトルにランダムなスピンを与えるようなものだ。解がちょうど1つだけある場合、ランダムなスピンで
状態ベクトルが|A1⟩の近くに押し込まれることもあるが、途中で止まることもある。解がたくさんある場合は
ランダムなスピンで状態ベクトルが円を何周もする可能性がある。だからこれで
確率1に近い形で解が得られるとは期待できないが、解があれば見つかる可能性は
かなり高い。実は常に40%以上だ。これは自明ではないが、そういう
結果になる。とはいえ驚くほどではない。真にランダムな角度では50%の確率で解が見つかる
わけだから。40%は悪くない。また、解が見つかる確率は
プロセスを繰り返すことで常に高められることを覚えておいてほしい。毎回Tを独立に選びながら繰り返すことで
解があるのに見つからない確率は繰り返し回数に対して指数的に減少する。99%の
確率で解を見つけたいなら、このシンプルなアプローチを10回実行すればいい。毎回Tを独立に選びながら
当然、解が見つからなければ「解なし」を出力する。解が存在しない場合は
解が見つかるはずがないので、その場合は常に正しい答え「解なし」を出力できる。解がある場合は
見つけられずに誤って「解なし」と宣言してしまうかもしれないが、その確率は非常に小さくできる
また、少し前に述べたように、これはBig O of root nのfのクエリ数または評価回数が必要だ
つまりGroverのアルゴリズムを使えば、解の数を事前に知らなくてもBig O of root n の
クエリ数で高い確率で探索問題を解ける。さらに洗練された
アプローチもあって、解の数が増えるにつれてクエリ数を減らせる。ただし詳細は説明せず
メインのアイデアだけに絞る。capital TをT=1から始める。次にランダムな反復回数でGroverのアルゴリズムを実行するが
上限はTだ。最初にステップ2に来たとき、1回の反復でGroverのアルゴリズムを実行するが、Tは
増加していく。解が見つかればその解を出力して止まる。解が見つからなければTを
大きくしてもう一度試みる。Tが大きくなりすぎる前のある時点でプロセスを終了させて
「解なし」と宣言する。基本的なアイデアはシンプルなアプローチと同じで
状態ベクトルにランダムなスピンを与えているが、ここではTが
小さい間は最初に軽いスピンから始める。解がたくさんある場合に備えてだ。こうすることで状態が
強く回転しすぎて円を何周もするような無駄なクエリを避けられる。しかし解が見つからなければもう一度試みる
少し強めに、あるいは潜在的に少し強めに回転させる。これをうまく機能させるには、Tの増加率を
慎重に選ぶ必要がある。うまく機能させる一つの方法は、TをTの天井(5/4乗)で置き換えることだ
つまりTは指数的に増加していく。直感的には毎回25%強めに回転させると考えられる
Tが指数的に増加することが分析上重要だ。なぜ5/4かと思うかもしれないが
機能する数値の一つというだけで、機能する値の範囲が実際にある。例えば2は機能しない。Tを
毎回2倍にするのは増加速度が速すぎて、軽いスピンのメリットを十分に活かせない。とにかくこの洗練された
方法のポイントは、必要なクエリ数について先ほどと同じ漸近的な境界が得られることだ
Big O of √(n/s)だが、解の数を事前に知らなくてよい。ちなみに
TがrootnになったらこのプロセスをEはで止められる。解がなければBig O of
root nのクエリ数でその結論に至れる。これがGroverのアルゴリズムで反復回数を選ぶ方法だ。レッスンを締めくくるにあたって
Groverのアルゴリズムについて簡単にいくつかコメントしておく。まずquery modelにおいて
Groverのアルゴリズムは漸近的に最適だ。これが意味するのは、探索問題を解くquery algorithmで
あるいはunique search問題を解くものでも、漸近的に
より少ないクエリ数を使うものを考え出すことは不可能だということだ
最悪の場合においてBig O of root endクエリより漸近的に少ない——これは厳密に証明できることだ
実際、この事実には複数の既知の証明が存在する。興味深いことに、これは
Groverのアルゴリズムが発見される以前から知られていた。Groverのアルゴリズムは、必要なクエリ数に関して既知の下界と一致したわけだ
時々、Groverのアルゴリズムより漸近的に優れていると思われるアプローチを考案する人がいるが、
常に何らかの間違いがあるか、関数fへのアクセス方法に関する仮定があるか、
その主張を誤りにする何らかの問題がある。query modelの枠組みで正しく作業する限り、
非構造化探索においてGroverのアルゴリズムを超えることはできない。第二に、Groverのアルゴリズムは
かなり幅広く適用可能だ。非構造化探索問題に対してGroverのアルゴリズムが提供する平方根の高速化は、
様々な異なる設定で得られる。例えば、Groverのアルゴリズムを別のアルゴリズムの
上位に使用して、そのアルゴリズムの性能を超える二乗の改善を得られることがある。Groverのアルゴリズムはまた、
他の量子アルゴリズムの中のサブルーティンとしても非常によく使われる。簡単な例として、
Groverのアルゴリズムを使って、第5回で触れた最小値問題において古典的アルゴリズムより二乗の優位性を得られる
そして最後に、Groverのアルゴリズムで使われる技術——二つの
反射を合成・反復して量子状態ベクトルを回転させる方法——はかなり
大きな形で一般化できる。例えば、振幅増幅と呼ばれる技術がある。これは、Groverのアルゴリズムを一般化したプロセスで、
別の量子アルゴリズムに適用することで、その成功確率を古典的な場合より二乗のオーダーで速く
高めることができる。この技術は量子アルゴリズムにおいて幅広い応用を持つ。Groverのアルゴリズムが実用的な量子優位性につながる可能性は低いかもしれないが、
いつかはともかく、Groverのアルゴリズムは
間違いなく根本的に重要で幅広く適用可能な量子アルゴリズムだ。多くの
用途を持つ、より一般的な技術を代表している。このレッスンおよびシリーズのこのユニット——量子
アルゴリズムについてのユニット——はここで終わりだ。query modelと、より標準的な計算モデルへの接続方法を論じた。それに加えて、
計算コストの測り方に関するいくつかの基礎的な概念も扱った。次に位相推定、
素因数分解、そして最後にGroverのアルゴリズムを取り上げた。既に示唆したように、
量子アルゴリズムについて学ぶことはまだたくさんあるが、このシリーズでは次のユニットで別のトピックに移る。特に、
量子情報の一般的な定式化を見ていく。そこでは量子状態が特定の種類の行列——
密度行列と呼ばれるもの——で表される。この定式化は非常に有用であり、
量子情報のいくつかの側面を理解するために不可欠だ。また、数学的な観点からも
かなり美しい。ぜひユニット3でも参加してほしい。それでは、また
次回